Film Courage: Do villains have defining moments?
Christopher Riley, Screenwriter, Author, and
Instructor: I think that they certainly can.
Sometimes we get villains who
are very cardboard cut out,
just gleefully wreaking havoc for the heck of
it. I think of a classic film Spider-Man 2 and
there Doc Ock has a defining moment. He isn’t
evil for the sake of evil, he is a man who is
wounded through the death of his wife, that's
the moment that defines him. In Spider-Man 2
written by the same writer who wrote
Ordinary People [Alvin Sargent]
we get a villain who actually has an
arc and who transforms and in the end
is able to take a step back from the
evil and to actually sacrifice himself
to join with Spider-Man and to save the
city. So yes, and I think that Spider-Man 2
plays a really important role in the
history of superhero action films.
We look back and we may not recognize that because
we're used to superhero action films that have
rich character development but Spider-Man 2
really took that up a huge step by in part
looking deeply in to the character
of their villain and by providing the
the depth and complexity and
dimension that defining moments
afforded that character and when we do see these
defining moments for these villains is it to to
have the audience turn to to have some empathy
toward that antagonist or is it just to further
understand the arc of the story I think the effect
is that we actually do have some empathy for that
villain and and it's not to say that we like the
villain or we agree with the evil the villain does
but it's to say that we recognize the villain's
humanity and we say oh you are at least a
little bit like me we are the same species and
there are a lot of different ways to approach
villains we can approach villains as other just
completely different from me and outside of me but
you think about Pinocchio so if we go way back
to a very disturbing children's animated film
a scene where Pinocchio is at the
pool hall and he and the other boys
are drinking and smoking cigars and playing
pool and being transformed into donkeys
that's a vision of evil that
says oh there is no difference
between us and them we are them and that is a
cautionary tale but it also does lead to a kind
of empathy where we can recognize oh that villain
is really broken and what they're doing may be
horrible and actually we may call it evil but they
are also one of us and for my storytelling money
that's that's closer to what I resonate
with as like yeah I think that's how it is
how are the decisions of the villain different
from the hero in many ways the hero and villains
decisions are the same they're driven by the
way they see the world and what they want when I
am writing an antagonist and I will often think
in terms of antagonist as opposed to villain
because villain is more condemning than I think
i'm i'm ready to be with most of my characters
Joseph Mengele certainly was a villain and
did pure evil and he was a human which is what
made him so interesting to me as a character
what allowed us to write
Joseph Mengele in a way that
I think was so disturbing and
ended up getting the actor
best actor nomination for the European film award
was that we approached him as a character who
thought he was the hero and I think that everyone
sees themselves as the hero of their story they
do what they do for the reasons they do them
and even when they do something that they
would recognize is like okay that was bad
but you have to understand I had a really
good justification why I had to do that
it's part of the genius of Michael Corleone's
character we understand with every choice he
makes why he makes it and we cringe because
sometimes he's killing family members
but we always recognize the reasons
that he does it and it creates this
cognitive dissonance for us
because we're saying oh no that's
like don't you shouldn't do that and at the same
time I totally understand why you just did that
I think that gives us really fascinating
antagonists and villains if we do we do the
same character development for them that we do
for any other character I don't think that means
we have to have really fuzzy moral judgment
I think we can still recognize evil as evil
and recognize the humanity of the people
who are doing the evil at the same time it's
a more nuanced approach I think it's more
interesting and I think again I think it
it rings true to me for how people actually are I
haven't like I don't think I've ever met a villain
at Von’s I’ve met people doing dumb things
and being irresponsible and uncaring
but they think they're right and
so I try to approach all my characters
with love even the ones that are wicked
how do writers get audiences to care about
the villains I think that on the one hand
you could get away with the audience not caring
about the villains even gleefully rooting
for the destruction of the villain
but the example of 2 shows us that there is
emotional gold to be mined in providing a
glimpse into the humanity of a villain so the in
the same way that we would reveal a character say
a heroic character to the audience so that they
can understand where that character's coming from
we can use those same tools to reveal
who this villain is and why this
villain is how what journey this character
has been on to arrive at their villainy
the I think the emotional experience then
becomes really complex because now I am
I recognize that character has to be stopped
i'm thinking of the camp commandant in
Schindler's List where we really do get
some insights into this character into his
vulnerability into there's there's a moment where
he toys with showing mercy to people and then
he pulls back from that it's like that's not me
i'm not i'm not going to
be that guy who is merciful
but the fact that he had that moment
where he could have been merciful
colors the way we feel about him when
he's executed at the end of the film
it makes it more complicated in a way that I think
enriches the experience never confuses us about
the evil that he's perpetrated the film never
has any confusion about that the evil is evil
but it does show us the complexity of
the person perpetrating the evil which
does I think make for a more
interesting storytelling experience.